today I'm gonna explain how the end of
my here academia and indeed the future
of cork society it's not all gonna be as
happy and cheerful as we're all assuming
now there are several converging
storylines including the oval arc the
remedial course and the walk that just
began in the manga they all kind of come
together into a threat but the heroes
can't defeat by traditional means and by
traditional means i mean a detroit smash
sorry Deku it's super important that you
guys watch this video the whole way as
I'm gonna explain how all the different
plot threads intertwine and then at the
end I'll tell you the likely way that my
hero academia has to end and I'm so
positive that this is it because for
this not to be the end it would leave
one glaring problem in the series
unsolved however before we begin I'm
super excited to announce that we
finally have our first ever legit
merchandise I've worked with two
brilliant artists over the last month to
bring these pieces to life both the
artists and I have a lot more ideas
planned if this goes well so if you want
to support me them or the channel then
consider getting something for yourself
or a friend but without further ado
let's get into the video so an episode
14 of season four we were introduced to
the concept of the quark singularity now
this is a theory that with each passing
generation different quark users mixed
together and have children and those
children are born with hybrid quarks
that are even stronger than either of
their individual parents now this
process continues to repeat over and
over until they will eventually come a
time where human beings are no longer
able to control or even tolerate the
power that's held inside them now this
concept of course going stronger has
been demonstrated many times throughout
the series with Todoroki and baku go
being the perfect fusion of both their
parents quirks but this new generation
of quark uses are the clearest examples
yet remember guys the first known quark
user was a baby who just radiated light
and while that's kind of cool it doesn't
really compare to having the ability to
rewind people or having a literal mouth
cannon or my second favorite quark of
all time being balls these kids aren't
just incredibly powerful but as present
mike said they are superior to his
generation at this age in every
conceivable way so what about when these
kids grow up and have kids of their own
and then what about when their kids have
kids and so on the notion that quarks
would become too powerful for the human
body to handle is by no means a
far-fetched theory and before
moving on it's also worth noting that
the two characters in minor academia who
unquestionably have the most knowledge
about quarks more than anyone else both
of them subscribe to this quote
singularity doomsday theory dr. Jick Oh
even uses the analogy that the hardware
of the human body can't keep up with the
software of quark evolution bearing that
in mind whilst overhaul was nothing
short of an absolute lunatic
there is one belief that he never
deviated from over all believed that
quote through a disease and that society
was infected he developed this belief
after learning that quarks originally
came from rats and so far this is the
only explanation that we've ever been
given as to why quarks manifested in the
first place and to be honest until
there's something introduced to the
contrary of this I'm inclined to believe
that her ago she put this in here
because it is in fact true quarks are a
disease that derived from rats and
whilst on the surface they seem to
empower society in reality is just a
ticking time bomb that's slowly killing
humanity over the generations and will
one day culminate in the day when no
single human will be able to control the
quirks inside them this will lead to the
extinction of the human race in just a
few more generations hell even the first
user of one for all set to deku that the
point of singularity has already been
passed and while I think he may have
been exaggerating a bit you can still
see where he's coming from characters
like Aoyama and Dobby they both suffer
the detrimental effects of their quirks
even the number one hero endeavor isn't
immune from the negative blowbacks of
using his quirk and he even referred to
Deku as one of us and what he meant by
that is that dec who is a person whose
quirk punishes his body for using it and
how could we even forget that back in
the day all swarm was dishing out quirks
like it was an episode of Oprah or
something and people genuinely couldn't
handle these quirks until they became
like brain-dead mummies this was all the
way back in the first generation when
quarks weren't even that great and on
top of all of that Dec who says in this
panel that human society without quarks
would have mastered interstellar travel
by now meaning that the manifestation of
quirks
is something that has prevented human
society from evolving technologically so
what we know is that while quirks do
have their upsides the fact is that as
long as quirks exists they essentially
put a limit on how many more generations
humanity can survive they've also
stunted technological advancements and
they have negative impacts on
body even for top heroes like endeavour
and most importantly they're growing too
strong too quick now before I explain
how everything interconnects and what
that means for the future of Kroc
Society I just want to mention this for
those of you that don't know horikoshi
is a massive Star Wars fan
in fact he's included more references
than I can count and while some of them
are clearly just for fun like having
r2d2 working for the villains for
example there are other references that
are way more meaningful at the very
start of Decker's journey all the way
back in episode 1 we see him rushing to
observe a fight outside Tatooine station
this is a very obvious parallel to Luke
Skywalker who is the protagonist of Star
Wars and who began his journey as well
on Tatooine although in his case
Tatooine was a planet and not a train
station but I know what you're thinking
how does this tie into the quark
singularity or the war for that matter
well for starters we know that in the
war the villains will vastly overpower
the heroes with an army of a hundred
thousand liberation soldiers and awaken
trigger our key no moves of all shapes
and sizes and twice on their side who
can manipulate and multiply all the no
Moo's single-handedly I'm sorry guys but
there's not one pro hero out there not
even wash who is capable of stopping all
of that so when the villains win this
war and believe me they will win what
would be the easiest way to consolidate
their power in Star Wars the Emperor
used an army of clones to consolidate
his power by getting them to
simultaneously kill most of the Jedi
across the galaxy with these clones
being manufactured on the planet Kamino
in my hero academia the town of Kamino
is where all for one and dr. Jacko were
manufacturing dozens of nomu this
parallel is very obvious and clearly
intentional and the logical follow-up is
that when sugar Aki becomes the emperor
equivalent the nomu will be used as a
method to eliminate the remaining heroes
the problem for the villains is that the
heroes who could survive that initial
onslaught will definitely not be easy to
kill so what if the villains use this
quark evolution through the generations
what if they manipulated that to their
advantage we've seen that dr. Hugo has
no problem using kids for his
experiments we know from the ultra
analysis book that he has connections to
several elementary schools across Japan
and it's heavily implied that he turned
his own grandson into a gnome ooh so to
me it's only logical that once the
villains take over dr. Yoko can use his
knowledge of the
singularity to get shigaraki to start
conscripted powerful children and either
turn them into no mousse or use awful
one to harvest their quotes from them or
alternatively he can brainwash them to
fight for the paranormal Liberation
Front which wouldn't be too dissimilar
from how the first order in Star Wars
kidnapped children across the galaxy and
then brainwash them to fight for evil in
this way Shikha rocky would have the
next generation of powerful quarks I his
disposal and could use it in any one of
the ways I just mentioned and this is
what leads me to my theory on how my
hero academia will eventually end I'm
looking way past the current series and
into the future where Deku is a pro hero
and shigaraki is probably long gone by
this point the problem that horikoshi
has with ending my hero academia is that
while you can destroy a villain like
Shigure aki or nine or all for one what
you can't defeat is something that is
almost intangible I'm not talking about
the million here the quote singularity
is not something that you can defeat in
a fight as long as quotes exist that
will always come a time where they've
mixed too much up until the point where
they can't be sustained by the human
body even if you could somehow magically
reset everyone's quark back to the power
level of the first generation where they
were easier to handle all you would have
done is delay the inevitable
on that basis my theory is that the end
of my year academia will result in a
mostly quirky society in which the quark
destroying drugs that overall
manufactured are in fact replicated on a
worldwide scale
I'm visited a system quite similar to
the current one in which professional
heroes are the only people allowed to
use their quirks and that those who have
quirks that are uncontrollable or have
no desire to become a hero they either
have their quirks cured or donated to
science in much the same way that dr.
huge eco is able to harvest individual
quarks and store them inside chips I
believe that in the future people could
voluntarily give up their quarks and
have them stored in this way I believe
the series will end this way because the
quote singularity is an inevitable thing
you can never get away from the
singularity every generation the course
will get stronger and stronger and
stronger and then you've got to ask
yourself why is horikoshi included
certain things so for example the fact
that the first user form form mentioned
the singularity to Deku and the fact
that little kids like every are
incredibly powerful
horikoshi is signalling at this he's
very much aware of the fact
quality getting stronger and given that
the overhaul arc is the longest arc
admire academia history it has a lot of
important things that would be relevant
to the series going forward now I've
always said the area is one of those
things but another one is the quirk
destroying bullets even that these
bullets completely destroy your quark
factor it would probably mean that if
people were given these bullets society
would eventually revert back to regular
society like it is in the real world as
if your quote factor is gone there's no
quote to be passed on if this was to pan
out it would still mean that Dec who
would become the greatest hero like he
told us because on the face of it it
doesn't really change too much I mean in
the current series most normal people
who are not heroes are not allowed to
use their quotes anyway so all you're
doing is making sure that those people
instead of just not using their quirks
they don't have quirks at all and this
isn't done to punish them but rather
it's done to protect them and indeed
protect the rest of society it's even
possible that at some point children
could just be given these drugs at birth
so that they're quote never manifests
but you never know maybe people might
even be begging to have their quirks
taken away
I'm sure characters like Airy would at
least appreciate the option for that to
happen but yeah guys that was my theory
my ear' academia will end with society
returning to a quirk less States or at
the very least a mostly quokka state in
which only the heroes are allowed to
possess quarks let me know what you guys
think is a return to Coakley Society
necessary for the survival of humanity
in my opinion it probably is the only
way you can really overcome it is if the
hardware of people evolves to keep up
with the software of quirks the only
person who's really made that happen is
dr. Zeko
and we all know he's evil as hell so
until a good scientist can come up with
a way to genetically modify the body of
future generations to handle their
powerful quirks bearing in mind that
this is a planet full of billions of
people I don't think it's gonna happen
but who knows maybe I'm wrong let me
know what you guys think how can the
heroes realistically deal with the quote
singularity we know that Dec whose mom
was like the fourth generation of quark
users so I'm guessing that kids like
Harry would be these six or seventh
generation so by the eleventh or twelfth
generation like how how are those kids
meant to survive let me know your
thoughts and thank you for watching and
be sure to check out in the merchandise
below this video peace out